today we are
to have as our keynote speaker the
assistant US attorney general for the
criminal division lanny breuer Lenny is
a graduate both of columbia college and
columbia law school and i think we all
will agree that his career in the law
stands as a model for new law school
graduates aspiring to weave together
private practice in public service at
the highest levels and in fact landing
not long ago visited campus just very
recently and spoke to our law school
students and encourage them to find a
place in their careers for public
service for the past two years assistant
attorney general Brewer has led nearly
600 criminal division attorneys in the
prosecution of federal criminal cases
across the nation through their work the
nation's criminal law is given meaning
and implemented in countless ways that
shape our society his responsibilities
demand that he focused on the most
urgent and contentious issues of the
time ranging from financial fraud and
national and international markets to
immigration and border control Lani has
also served as special counsel in the
White House for President Clinton before
hearing from lani we have a videotaped
message from a special guest attorney
General Eric Holder knowing Lani I'm
confident that he is comfortable sharing
the stage with the Attorney General but
here again we have a double degree from
Columbia credentials both from the
college and the law school Eric's
unwavering devotion to Columbia is
evidenced in many ways I've heard him
say as I've heard Lani say there's
nothing he won't do for Columbia but
he's also served as a trustee of the
University there's no question that the
Justice Department
has a blue and white cast these days
much can be said about attorney general
holders career in the law many of you
know him as a native New Yorker who
after leaving columbia has had an
outsized impact on our nation's justice
system his career is defined by
leadership and service and it is a
testament to Eric that three different
US presidents have called on him to
serve President Reagan nominated him to
the Superior Court of the District of
Columbia President Clinton made him
Deputy Attorney General and now
president Obama has asked him to lead
the Justice Department we are very happy
to have him part of our program today